brandon woodruff making his first start
of the season against the saint louis
cardinals chris but he has been
otherworldly on the mound so far this
year yeah one of the
top pitchers and most fun to watch in
the national league and he's off to the
best start of his career you look at
those numbers a 173
era going in on them and a swing and a
miss
first strike out of the night for
brandon woodruff
yeah you can see a little tardy there
carlson down to the zone something
better for him to handle than
the elevated fastballs he saw earlier in
the bat but you could tell
sitting a little bit off speed trying to
stay in between really had some
explosion out of the hand to get a
right-hander to buckle on a pitch that
ended up
on the outside edge got him blew him
away
98 mile an hour fastball from brandon
woodruff
we're off and running in milwaukee
brewer's coming up gant getting the
start tonight
and you mention it in the open bread
it's been the walks that have been the
problem
he gets runners on he is playing with
the
fire there but yet gets out of it and a
swing and a miss
first strikeout for gan it's kind of a
funky swing right there from shaw
runner's head first and second garcia
whacks it out to left
but there's tyler o'neill so again two
runners on
left stranded for john cann brandon
woodruff prior to last year would
play catch with his wife in the off
season as bader hits one
foul territory down the right field line
vogel back
makes the catch big dan ran it down
i think the sidewall was very concerned
about the train coming its direction
it's a great job of sticking with this
it's so hard you wander into foul
territory you get to that warning track
and
don't know exactly where you are
concentration has to be
excellent nothing in two here on can one
away
nobody on top of the third no score and
the pitch swing and a miss
98 right past gant
great history with that franchise 2-2
pitch swing and a miss
dropped a curveball in there and edmond
swung through it couple of strikeouts in
the inning for brandon woodruff
another one two three against this
cardinals lineup we go to the bottom of
the third zero zero ball game
is wong hits it out to left diving
forward with catch
tyler o'neal robs coldwog nice play by
tyler o'neill on the ball hit by colton
wong yeah this is a heckler play you
know the ball
off the bat it's going to be tailing
towards the line it's sinking he does a
good job sticking with it you see the
eyes never leave the baseball
man he's squared up like he's ready to
tackle you
and then he goes into that wind up and
then brings the heat
there it is he just carved up nolan
aronado with that 98 mile an hour two
seamer
five strikeouts for brandon woodruff
through four
[Music]
2-2 and a cold third strike strikeout
number two for john gann
this pitch wasn't exactly where john
gant wanted it but
it does catch the corner right here 78
miles an hour change up
up and in garcia obviously not happy
about it
the one-two pitch swing and a miss threw
it by him up and in a good cutter from
gant back to back strikeouts and maybe
he did have a little bit of a
calming meeting on the cardinals bench
in between innings because he's come out
firing here
in the fourth two and two of the count
got him strikes out the side here in the
bottom of the fourth
four strikeouts tonight three in this
inning and there's no score
got one job one job protect you
oh two strike three called 98 at the
knees
strikeout number six for brandon
woodruff that is a
perfect pitch good she did everything
bouncer hit wide of a diving urease gets
up
throws in plenty of time to retire
yadier molina can't believe that one
a diving stab to his left and then
with molina running somebody else maybe
he doesn't get him but he threw a
one-hop strike
to daniel vogelback and molina is gone
in case his score give that one 6-3 with
a star
two down for tyler o'neill
check swinging with six strikeouts for
brandon woodruff
a beauty through five for woody woodruff
squares to bun again
funded in the air get the catch throw to
first and double play
edmond snuck in behind him it's a double
play
how about that got him to pop this bad
boy up a fastball up in the zone
gant pounces on it and tommy edmond
this is played to perfection right now
all they're thinking about is trying to
score a run
edmond tries to punt lays it down
woodruff off the mount bare hand throw
to the first vogel back
picked it two away great on both ends
just incredible athleticism there had to
go into a little bit of a back pedal
before the determination brandon
woodruff
had to make the play bare-handed it as
well
one-two pitch now struck him out fast
ball at 96.
eight strikeouts for brandon woodruff
cardinals strand a runner at third
trying to get big lose some runs and the
easy cheese
and i'd say shaw is due he had some good
swings off of the lefty kim
last night swinging a fly ball hit well
to center
bader drifting back onto the warning
track slips and falls
still makes the catch kane is gonna head
to third
they're gonna try and send him around
here's the relay throw home
not in time
kane dashes two bases and is able to
score as harrison vader made the catch
on the warning track
slipped the ball popped out and kane
scored
wow you see the footing lost by bader
but a tremendous job of recovering
to at least make the catch and as soon
as jason lane saw that ball
pop away from harrison vader kane was
getting the windmill tyler o'neal over
two tonight
and o'neal lifts a high fly ball out
deep right
it may go gone the game is tied
tyler o'neal with one out here in the
eighth
takes him deep we're tied 1-1
we've been saying it all game dan all it
takes is
one that's it and it was one slider here
it didn't even look like it was crushed
off the bat but just strong
is tyler o'neal lets this one travel
one two swing and a miss it gets by
yadier molina
vogel back hustling to first not in time
vogel back reaches pablo reyes is the
runner over at first
shaw against helsley all for one shaw to
right center
it's headed for the gap it's down
on his horse pablo reyes he rounds third
there will be a throw not in time
travis shaw coy had double in the eighth
well better late than never
and a huge smile there from reyes
come off the bench pitch run and better
make sure those hamstrings are loose
as he had to get it into top speed right
away shaw hit this ball
so hard got to the wall and got off that
wall pretty quickly
off the wall pablo reyes was wide open
man when he hit third base
he was rocking and rolling swinging left
and deep
get up get up get out of here
and the brewers now lead on the long
shot by garcia wow
he knew he got it when he hit it
and took the long slow trot around
and the brewers
tag on a couple of more
second out of the inning and now you got
to deal with yadier molina
2-2 pitch struck him out with a slider
ball game over brewers take down the
cardinals by a final of four to one
breathe easy sleep fast